hello everybody still the locksmith in
this video
reprogramming your key all keys loss to
a 2016 Honda CRV proximity push to start
using the altel K100 and a universal I
key
first let's generate the key we'll go to
Universal key
make
and choose Honda
yeah model CRV
here
2016.
okay here's our two choices
let's choose this one first one here
we'll click generate Universal key
okay generation is complete we'll press
complete
I'll just go to Imo
it's push to start
yes
control unit
keyless system
is the ignition turned on by pressing
stop button twice
one
two
nope so we say no
press and hold
it okay the ignition is forced on
you say okay
oh key is lost
it's on the ignition off
okay
we have only the key to be learned in
the vehicle
you say okay
no
press and hold
let me just switched on okay
now it is not a new model
just want to do one key
one
okay
switch ignition off
switch ignition on so we'll go one two
mission is on
yes immobilizer light is out
yes
switch ignition off
ignition on one two
registration is complete switch ignition
off
looks like that all the keyless access
remotes work okay
unlock
and let's try to start it
time will test out the remote
unlock
I'll try to start the car
2016 Honda CRV
it's all keys lost with the autel cam
100 and a universal ikey thank you for
watching have a great day